laughs father wait other way for the way
stop moving stop spinning step let me
focus let me focus I owe all my success
to red bull so I was just going on a
coffee run as I'm driving back to the
studio across the river I see this huge
plume of black smoke rising from right
where our studios I'm curious to see
what is on fire because it looked like
it was right where we work pretty nice
at the fire next door seems like they
start on fire every year
[Music]
Oh subscribe power lines are on fire
should the rock retreated me today
[ __ ] life goals this place starts on
fire every six months or so what
repercussions do they offer to the city
for having to come down here and put out
their fires all the time how are they
still in business how is the fire
department not shut them down or the
city not shut them down the only answer
is that it must somehow be related to
city activity generally if a private
business around here started on fire
every six months they would be shut down
so fast nothing would happen in that
location yet somehow these guys operate
every single day and literally this
place starts on fire every six month
yeah the [ __ ] garbage starts on fire
but the Transformers blow up and then
who replaces that the taxpayers and then
that [ __ ] blows up we don't have power
then we can't work how's that work man
like Silent Hill up there while I got ya
super weird I was never expecting to be
a teacher but I'm getting a bit old are
the children your teacher well they're
not children anymore is like college
like 19 20 year old children mostly mr.
P are teaching like illustration and
like art or things like that
illustrator like satanic technical be
getting the hang of it was it hard to
teach people what's the challenge we
find them teaching the time is that
everyone was like at different levels
there's some that get it right away and
there's some that take a lot longer
basically need to come up with course
syllabuses for like advanced and
intermediate and beginner the more
advanced I just let them get ahead like
give him extra stuff I tell them they in
the beginnings like as long as you do
your work good pass the thing is look
when I was first year in school I feel
like I did a couple of those film
courses where you learn Final Cut Pro
you know it's like I already knew Final
Cut Pro going into these classes and I
wasn't taking it necessarily just to
learn the the program but to like use it
just get experienced shooting videos so
I mean I definitely feel for those those
advanced students
because it's all about just like keeping
busy like today I pretty much told them
like you just have to pretty much make
an ad like make a product from scratch
so most of them are like what they're
just gave me this why'd I look and I was
like let's do it in two weeks so that's
great no that's great you guys start it
in 13 days they're gonna start like 13
days of it they open up like Photoshop
Illustrator is like a necessary evil for
me to be honest
so this watch video we just did there's
a character in it who's completely CGI
it's a digital watch face but we want to
animate that face so it actually feels
like a real character adobe has this
program called character animator and we
actually talked about it in a video
about a year ago on this channel and
we're gonna try to use that for real or
this video to streamline the animation
process imagine being able to be like
I'm going to literally act as the watch
hit record do all your facial animation
stuff and is capturing all this and
adding keyframes all the different
features of the digital face so it'll
literally translate like my eyebrow
movement to like keyframes that you can
adjust to whatever you want and it does
all of this just off of tracking it from
a webcam right Gabe has gone through and
done the pass of the animation here but
we've gone through and also tweak things
basically our watch face up it is ready
to go I'm gonna go through here using
this contraption that gave us the byes
get some action on this washed face here
for the video I'm gonna the video pulled
up on one side and I've got the audio
plugged into the animation so I don't
need to actually speak but all my facial
expressions are gonna be a ran through
the animation and then also I'm gonna be
using keyboard commands to trigger other
events
oh I see it there it is I don't want to
fly if there any helicopters nearby cuz
that's against the law I don't want to
make them worried about us so I've been
keeping my distance look at the smoke
there so that's a big look at that
simulation ain't no fume effects boy
yeah someone's having a street meat
barbecue Street mate those firefighters
got balls man takes a lot of balls to
climb on top of a burning building yeah
when you don't exactly know where the
fire is coming from and punch a hole in
the ceiling so that it like doesn't
combust underneath you first the fire is
coming out of the chimney that's that
fire star that that chimney stack there
the fires coming out there and now it's
gone all the way over to the left side
of the building so I guess the fires
spread internally notice how like the
light hitting that side of the smoke
makes of lighter but the further into
the smoke it goes the darker and orange
rotational is yellow room that's yeah
that's that's absorption and scattering
it's really cool to see this in real
life I mean I guess not but not like the
smoke I love it
you randomly that the works not admin
this is
what it works really well okay so for
some context real quick there's on yeah
yeah you like you need context okay
there's a piece and in the video where
the watch falls and then helicopters
backup it it's stupid it's really stupid
instead of like doing a CG watch and
spending it if we thought it would be a
really good idea to put it on a drill
and spin it it saves this time and it'll
look real because it is real that's a
great idea
alright so what we did was we put an
Ellen wrench and drill and now we're
gonna put some green tape right around
the top here it is tape look how is this
not tape you see this it's like it's not
tape that's a cloth that's double-sided
tape yeah it's a trick I reach for tape
and a spool of carpet unfold unrolls in
my hand that's not it's a role of a
Fowler table its role a role of felt
because this is has that felt material
it absorbs light so it's gonna be a more
consistent right for that one insert
shot that's going to be spinning around
it like 60 miles an hour motion blur
like that no one's ever you you're not
the one doing the shot green-screen
drill bit as you guys know a large part
of what we do is supported directly by
you through our patreon we are trying to
up the ante and I'll tell you why we've
been doing more and more salmon eco
videos and the more and more we do the
more and more manpower needs to go into
making salmon eco videos so if we can
get our monthly patreon total up to
$7,500 we are going to be giving you
guys a free vlog exclusive to patrons
only every month so for five dollars a
month you will get one exclusive salmon
eco vlog you get the hang outs and cheer
in your heart by knowing that you're
helping us make salmon eco videos and
corridor videos we're not charging for
the vlogs we're not we're not charging
for the vlogs so just stop that comment
right there okay all we're saying is
that if we get our patreon up to seventy
five hundred dollars a month we will
reward you guys by giving you another
salmon nicovideo that's exclusive
content to just that video next time
you're at
Starbucks and you're about to buy a
large front pocket Chino or next time
you're at Subway and you're about to get
a footlong do just get that six inch and
help us out man we're better than a
Frappuccino yeah so check out patreon
links in the description thank you guys
so much if you already support us enjoy
the video let's get to 75 there is
Wednesday my dudes and it is a very
tense day for tor digital I'm gonna boy
on the floor messin with tape what he
thinks is tape that's actually about it
everything else is pretty good now how's
the adhesive-backed
carpet working for you pretty damn good
Sam you're in our spot Nick move it move
it go you're here let's try it again
it's interesting
hell is pretty soft that's pretty good
let's watch it in slow motion that's
perfect what are you talking about
that's pretty good that's pretty good
like when it starts up is like like
that's perfect
alright let's move on loading what up
today the Red Bulls stopping by to drop
off a corridor Red Bull fridge and a
supply of films before you fling it off
Blackheart away further wait for the way
it's time to get that Red Bull fridge so
we can fly back you know I owe all my
success to Red Bull it's it's more of a
status symbol it's like having a gold
chain around your neck the brandon got
hooked up at the monster fridge and we
were kind of envious but then we started
realizing that like monster was kind of
gross
i mean people still drink it because
sometimes being a little kick it's got
adhesive on the mexican strips and Sam
hates this for some reason it's really
expensive yeah
that's mostly why I hate him like I just
want some green tape son don't give you
this
Golf Cart green frickin roll of carpet
with adhesive lining
[Music]
Obie's oh he's not sure about this
Obi you know what I haven't done in a
while just the classic cleat cleaner you
know everybody used to play baseball and
you get dirt in your cleats and huh
feels good
[Music]
[Laughter]